come on
what was his plan
so how's he not just like snapping his
ribs in that shot
hi welcome to the first episode of
stuntman react i'm not a professional
stunt man clint isn't so we're actually
joined here by a longtime friend and
incredible stunt professional here eric
linden he's uh both a stunt man a stunt
coordinator as we like to call him a
stunt lord
stunt commander
eric tell us a little bit about yourself
been in the business now for 14 years do
things like crash cars and wireworks
fight daredevil this is a punisher stunt
double coordinated punisher season two
we're gonna sit down here we're gonna
take a look at some awesome stun shots
some stunts perhaps gone wrong and
hopefully learn a little bit about like
the magic behind the stunts how is this
illusion of people hurting each other
achieved without people significantly
damaging their bodies all right i'll
only jump into one
yeah mi6
sweet tom cruise take some knocks for
being 56 years old
god hit him with that laptop so hard
right
oh so sick
oh god dude just kills him right there
dude the move the move where he like
twists himself in midair is my favorite
right there
and then the throw yeah
dude
then he bounced off of his back off i'm
guessing in this scene when it comes to
his close-up just some dude like
throwing some mere bits on him the guy
like falls over 100
so how's he not just like snapping his
ribs in that shot i you know he's
rehearsed it probably a hundred times
with no mirror not to mention he's
padded up where he's gonna hit and then
also i'm guessing that that thing is
rubberized a lot of times what they're
gonna do in a big scene like this is
that they literally make like insulite
which is uh very thin but dense foam and
they'll cover the entire ground
and make it look like tile so that when
you know henry cavill hits the ground
not only does he have pads on sometimes
they're even sewn into his clothing but
literally the floor is completely padded
there's a part where tom cruise
collapses onto the urinals i'm wondering
if you can see an indent where his knee
pushes down on it can you see it oh yeah
you see it pushed down oh yeah yeah that
was a pad look at this look at this look
at that knee boom
yeah yeah it squishes right there yeah
it's just a nerf bathroom yes
almost every single thing in there is
more than likely padded i love that it's
awesome i love how
cruises like i need to break
that's awesome do you think cruz took
that hit there he did what a cool
breakaway wall too
onto a pad like a hidden floor like you
were talking about exactly yeah i got a
lot of respect for how much tom cruise
throws himself into the action scenes
tom cruise has always wanted to do his
own stuff
and so i think that happened maybe on
mi3 the producers
wouldn't let him him do any of his own
stunts basically what he did he was like
well then i'm going to produce it
so he became the producer on all the mi
movies since he's the boss he can just
say i'm doing it wow so you're like
hyper aware of any time somebody's like
punches are off by a couple inches and
stuff yeah right here is miss doesn't
connect right here
they're like we'll put the sound in
you'll never know
i mean i think cavill missed a punch
when he was throwing a straight or two
when cavill reloads his freaking biceps
i mean
that that is action gold
they have like
chicks
regardless of whether their timing is on
or off you need to like adjust to them
the guy they're fighting here is he's a
stunt man as well as an actor he can
kind of help these guys part of the
stuntman job is to help the actor look
good so how do you sell a punch because
the camera's seeing something that's in
2d as long as you're stacking it kind of
past the person's head the camera can't
tell depth you can be this far away from
clint's face so if you're going to punch
me in the head right now yeah can you
demonstrate i'd probably go in front and
you would match it as i go across yeah
with the help of sound and editing
sometimes like on this right here as he
starts to move we're going to cut to the
other side which is him whipping his
head towards camera
okay
[Music]
oh god
oh that was cool that was cool yeah they
are well aware of who kylo ren is
and they're all super cool and you're
treating it like this come on i will do
a kata behind you
oh what a move dude i saw arya stark do
that move
what's he doing what was his plan
[Laughter]
how do you guys feel about the scene
tomorrow i hadn't seen this movie you
haven't seen this movie who's this guy
is he all big is he a big guy
eric you need to get clint straightened
out because every vfx react episode
clint's like i haven't seen this movie i
take it that you're not a huge fan of
this scene no i really am not but let it
be known that i'm like a huge star wars
fan so that's why when like i see
something like this it really truly
hurts my soul i've never seen this movie
before i've used this for the first time
just now it's kind of average it was
just like an average fight scene like
nothing special but what makes it bad
like what's so bad about it well go go
to the beginning
i mean look at the guy in the far back
left he just like spent he does like
360.
he's just like all right
fight time 360. let's go if you watch
them in between each move the stunt guys
who i'm sure are phenomenal and probably
super on it realize daisy and kylo ren
there they're late so
every time they spin backwards into
their move they're just pausing in their
little pose and waiting for them to be
ready and then coming in and attacking
on time now they all spin away instead
of going into it an additional attack
she kicks one of them they all spin away
look at what's this cat doing he's just
waiting
there's just a ton of waiting and
pausing clearly you're disappointed this
scene what would you have done to make
this better i certainly would have used
some force powers in there in the new
the new trailer you see you know ray
flipping over a tie fighter like none of
them leave the ground she certainly
could have like made it to the other
side of somebody maybe box them into a
circle this fight seems to actually lack
tactics in its entirety when qui-gon and
obi-wan are fighting the droids what is
awesome about that is none of the droids
are there so they're not looking at what
the next droid is they're just there and
they're killing the droid it truly looks
like the force is guiding them where to
go and they do none of this like daisy
needs to look at who's coming next uh
are they late are they on okay i'm gonna
block it so it needs to feel effortless
but it doesn't they do get a couple of
points back for this move here yeah i
mean that was great
this is one i really wanted to get eric
london's response on i know jackie chan
cites buster keaton a lot is one of his
biggest inspirations yeah the thing i
love about old black and white movies is
there's zero cg like you know they are
doing this for real for the camera on
the train train's like the most
dangerous thing to work with for sure
important to keep in mind is like if you
slip you die
like you get run over chopped up by a
train
yes like this this is insane
wait
oh that's pointed right at him
oh my god this is nuts this right here
is one of my favorite stunts that buster
keaton's ever done
oh no no way
oh stop it
it's so funny i like difficulty level is
very high even though it's not like
it's not huge yeah but if he would have
hit that wow that was hits him in the
face if he didn't pull it off he could
actually derail the train yeah that was
good see buster keaton's like a d d
character who has like a 20 for his
agility it's time to start talking i'm
not the one who's gonna be talking
what we're about to watch right here is
a fight scene from uh the punisher and
this from season two now you were the
stunt coordinator on that yes which if
i'm not mistaken that means that you're
basically responsible for kind of
directing the stunts doing the
choreography as well as figuring out how
it's all going to be shot so something
that we'll do is create a previz where
we literally sometimes go to the
location have a bunch of stunt guys just
kind of in their sweatpants we lay down
pads but we shoot all of the action and
work out the choreography so that then
you can show the director and the
producers to make sure that you're
getting as close to what they want as
possible a lot of times if they stick to
that road map i find the scenes come out
great
[Applause]
as you can see uh we didn't have
all the necessary personnel there so we
made boxes for a character oh my god and
for a previews this sure looks great
to just that would murder somebody
oh
in the teeth
oh dude broken leg
man a stunt scene shot by stunt guys
that's been choreographed by stunt guys
like it looks so good
the previous cell part
this is very close and i think that they
did a phenomenal job with it there it is
oh that guy took it even better in this
one yeah
so they didn't bring the prop leg
this is brutal man
he's selling the punches really well i
just kind of wanted john to get his ass
kicked a little bit
uh because i mean you always see him
just ripping through everybody berthold
is doing a great job of doing the
fighting he did all of it
the whole thing
john bernthal is an absolute savage
oh oh oh this is so good oh my god dude
come on
ugh why am i laughing so much this
matter just like hurting themselves it's
so much fun
oh are they on blades i like how the one
guy's like i'm staying on my bike he's
got his helmet they all got their
helmets this is definitely the best way
yeah
i'm the safest on this bike dude did you
see that guy die
did you see that guy just died
oh god
how sketchy is that dude
would you do that would you just go for
that like i got this how the [ __ ] i
don't even know how he did that did he
really do that i think he did it i think
you just did it
oh
it looks like they really did that man
it's insane are these guys just taking
full contact hits in the scene like when
he kicked him in the head like that guy
he really did kick him in the head you
know he's pulling it a little bit
there's some advantage in knowing that
it's gonna happen so as soon as he makes
contact you're moving with it yeah but
that's what's so great about these fight
scenes and these type of movies they are
very real and these stunt guys are
really just going for it wow you got a
freaking atv comes in i got four wheels
there are doors guys it's
this is crazy it's like one wrong move
in your skull
do this move oh
oh no
[Music]
that effects guy had to pop that like as
soon as his foot left oh my glass you
don't think they just drove an atv
through it to break it wait let's rewind
it see if it breaks before the thing
hits it so when you have to break
tempered glass in a movie usually you'll
have a special effects guy actually
rigged up basically they're like little
hammers that go on each side of the
glass you hit that and that'll actually
shatter the glass because tempered glass
is super super hard so you see so he's
on real glass so his foot leaves you
like you have like 10 frames
he's like yeah the atv hasn't hit it yet
that's oh it does break before you hit
it because the whole thing breaks like
it doesn't break like right there and
then shatter the rest of it the whole
thing
cracks that was like 15 frames where his
foot comes off the glass
and then the atv plows right through it
yeah like the effects guy had to wait
for his foot to leave the glass before
he could even hit it i mean that was rad
i hope you've all enjoyed getting an
insight into the world of stunts
choreography and all these crazy risks
and i guess dangers and odd skill sets
that these people have and i think eric
you've you've opened up a window here
that we otherwise wouldn't have and i
really thank you for coming out here and
sharing that all with us oh yeah thank
you for having me it's a lot of fun to
break this stuff down with you guys if
you're interested in seeing what i'm up
to pretty much everything i have on
social media and websites and everything
is all eric linden if you guys want to
see any other stunts uh in any of these
future videos please leave a comment
down below we read them all we'll take
the best ones and we'll do another one
of these if you guys haven't please
consider subscribing to the corridor
crew channel we've been doing a lot of
cool projects not only stunt related or
visual effects related but a whole bunch
of interesting experiments